[Música]
vamos a cambiar de tema y ahora vamos
con nuestro primer invitado del día y el
tema por supuesto sigue siendo de santis
que se ha convertido en una figura
notable de la política estadounidense
promotor de la polarización en torno a
derechos humanos y defensor de los
llamados valores tradicionales en su
estado que ha convertido en terreno de
prueba para políticas conservadoras
ahora el gobernante de Florida quiere
apostarle a la Casa Blanca por encima
del Magnate Donald Trump que sería el
candidato obvio de los republicanos tras
anunciar su aspiración junto a elon musk
analizaremos esa movida y su perfil para
ello vamos a conectar con Daniel García
Peña Jaramillo profesor de la
Universidad Nacional de Colombia y
especialista en Estados Unidos además de
columnista del medio del espectador
Muchísimas gracias a usted Daniel por
estar con nosotros
buenos días cómo están tenemos que
empezar hablando por lo que ha sido
tendencia y es esta campaña que ha sido
tildada de desastroso en vez de santis
disaster Usted qué opina sobre todos los
inconvenientes que tuvo este lanzamiento
de campaña y bueno como esto Podría
tener un impacto en esta carrera que
apenas comienza
no yo creo que sí efectivamente fue un
fiasco desde todo punto de vista se
buscaba hacer algo nuevo novedoso
distinto que lo mostraba como un
candidato moderno joven distinto a Trump
y y generó todo lo contrario fue lo ha
mostrado es el rey de burlas no no logró
mandar su mensaje y la noticia Hoy está
en torno a al al fracaso que tuvo
Twitter a la la incapacidad que tuvieron
para manejar algo que estaba previsto
pero más allá de eso también es parte de
la de la mala suerte y la el el momento
inoportuno en la cual de santis está
lanzando su candidatura él le de hecho
la semana pasada es la pelea que tiene
con Disney con Walt Disney World pues
Disney anunció que iba a suspender un
proyecto de inversión muy importante en
la Florida
la semana pasada también se lanzó otro
contendor Team Scott el que le quitó
quitó un poco la el foco de atención que
él buscaba de tal manera que lo que se
esperaba que iba a ser el anuncio del
Gran contector contra Trump pues parece
haber salido muy mal Bueno hay que
hablar además que en los titulares del
día de hoy no están sus propuestas de
campaña no están estas líneas que
esperan recoger los medios de
comunicación para tener pistas de en qué
sentido ir al candidato sino las burlas
que se dieron alrededor de esta campaña
ahora hablando más en términos de lo que
ha promovido este gobernador y en ese
contexto de las medidas aprobadas en su
estado usted cree que eso podría ser una
radiografía de lo que pasaría a nivel
nacional porque en Florida hay rechazo
también a sus medidas muy conservadoras
podría esto replicarse en los votantes
del resto del país
yo creo que que es una muy buena
pregunta y que tiene que ver
precisamente con Cómo el país está cada
vez más polarizado hay un sector del
país indudablemente de derecha en la
mayoría de la Florida que seguramente
aplaude muchos de las medidas de de de
de de
eso de atacar lo que él llama el
alucinamiento por parte de la izquierda
radical en las escuelas públicas en sus
medidas contra los inmigrantes ilegales
el suposición frente al aborto son
posiciones que van a tener digamos apoyo
en los sectores más de derecha en
diferentes partes del país pero lo
cierto es que eso puede ayudarle en las
elecciones primarias que republicanos
pero en las elecciones generales genera
todo lo contrario en el en los sectores
de los Estados Unidos que lo están
viendo
inclusive más a la derecha que el propio
Trump de de tal manera que el satis pues
puede estar apostándole por a la
candidatura republicana con estas
posiciones extremas Pero por otro lado
se pone en cuestión Hasta qué punto su
argumento central y es que él es
elegible mientras que Trump no lo es
pueda tener efectivamente alguna alguna
resonancia en el país justamente que
tendría que hacer de santis para
arrebatarle los votos a Trump fue porque
hasta el momento le lleva 30 puntos de
ventaja El Magnate y además que ha
manejado un discurso según el cual
gracias a él es que de santis logró la
gobernación de la Florida gracias a él
es que ron de santis es quién es
pero realmente no no tengo la la fórmula
creo que es la pregunta que se están
haciendo No solamente de Santi sino
muchos otros republicanos de cómo
descargar adorar tu nombre es increíble
que el Trump con la presidencia
desastrosa que tuvo ese final terrible y
el seis de enero la
imputación criminal que le hicieron en
el caso de la extraña de porno de la
orden del juez de tener que pagar cinco
millones de dólares a otra mujer acoso
sexual en cualquier país del mundo
cualquier otro candidato cualquiera de
estas escándalos serían un elemento
negativo Pero es increíble como logra
convertir todos esos elementos
a su favor pintándose como una víctima
del establecimiento Y utilizando su
capacidad de más como un hombre de de de
de de de no cierto de la del
entretenimiento el que creó un político
y en ese sentido pues hasta ahora nadie
ha logrado la fórmula para para derrotar
y y y y y por parece que podremos estar
ante un escenario semejante al 2016
cuando aparecieron muchos candidatos en
contra de Trump cada uno de ellos una
estrategia distinta pero lo cierto Es
que se dividieron el voto contra Trump y
Y aunque Trump tiene una base muy
importante no le da no es suficiente no
es mayoría para ganar pero si nosotros
se divide en la votación en su contra
pues pareciera que hoy el camino de
trompo será hasta la candidatura
republicana pues está bastante despejada
nos queda ya menos de un minuto pero
quisiera preguntarle para ir también del
otro extremo de la balanza Cuáles son
los puntos fuertes de rondes antes
bueno
se suponía que era un hombre que podría
mostrar hechos concretos él dice que
Trump habla mucho pero logra poco en
cambio en la gobernación Ha logrado
estas leyes que hemos mencionado
de alguna manera mostrado con una
persona mucho más pulida que Trump pero
pero este este lanzamiento fue un
desastre Porque si la idea era mostrarse
como un hombre que pueda cumplir con lo
que está haciendo que podríamos ser más
más modernos y más Pulido Pues creo que
este lanzamiento en vez de ayudarle le
quitó puntos pues mire Muchísimas
gracias Daniel García Peña Jaramillo
especialista en temas de Estados Unidos
que tenga un feliz día
muchas gracias a ustedes Igualmente este
hay otros temas continuaremos
analizandolos en minutos sigan con
nosotros y ya volvemos con directo a
América
[Música]